Seinfeld is undoubtedly one of the greatest
and most important TV comedies of all time.
It's been off the air for nearly 20 years,
but millions still watch the reruns every
day, both in syndication and online.
After nine seasons and 180 episodes, plenty
of on-set silliness was left on the cutting
room floor.
Here are some of the funniest bloopers from
the set of Seinfeld.
Not camera-worthy
Nothing ever seems to go right for unlucky
loser George Costanza.
It would seem that some of that bad luck rubbed
off on actor Jason Alexander, at least in
this blooper.
The camera is supposed to follow him off-screen,
but it doesn't …
"Let me just check.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, there's not a camera on me, and
it really ..."
Throw about nothing
The main characters of Seinfeld have been
called a lot of things—selfish, misanthropic,
self-absorbed.
They all tend to feed off of each other's
nasty energy, and that's on display in this
blooper.
George, Jerry, and Elaine irritate George's
hospital roommate, so George tosses a cup
over the partition.
Or at least he tries to …
"Shut up!"
"Ow ow ow!"
The way the scene crumbles
Whether or not a cookie can be made into a
paste and forced into the mouth of an unconscious
man is a debate you'll only find on Seinfeld,
but the insanity was too much for Jerry and
Julia during this take …
"Cookies don't liquefy!"
"Yes they can!
You can liquefy a cookie!"
Kramer vs. Kramer
Michael Richards is just naturally funny.
The role of Kramer often required him to be
funny with just a look, a gesture, or by just
plain existing, a challenge he executed a
little too well sometimes, cracking up his
castmates and ruining the take …
"I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, it's just that it's so funny!"
"Okay, we're rolling."
"We're f---ed up now, I don't know!"
No part for you
TV Jerry Seinfeld was a stand-up comedian,
just like the real Jerry Seinfeld.
And like his real-life counterpart, TV Jerry
sought out some supplemental acting work on
occasion.
But the fictional Seinfeld was not nearly
as successful as the real deal ...
"I can't act!
I don't know what the hum duh helm!
Because I …"
"See?
I can't."
Bubbling over
Season 4's "The Bubble Boy" ranks among the
silliest and most memorable Seinfeld episodes.
In one scene, Jerry can't stop himself from
jumping the gun and explaining what a "Bubble
Boy" is ...
"A Bubble Boy?"
"Yes, he lives in a bubble."
"What's a Bubble Boy?"
"Well, I think Jerry just explained that."
"He's a what?"
"He's a Bubble Boy."
"A Bubble Boy?"
"He lives in a bubble.
I'm sorry — my fault, my fault."
"He's a Bubble Boy.
"A Bubble Boy?"
"Yes, he lives in a bubble."
"You schmuck!
Will you wait!"
George wigs out
After six seasons, the self-consciously bald
George did something about his problem and
got himself a toupee.
His newfound sense of confidence draws new
attention from the opposite sex.
George somehow manages to play it cool, and
then, actor Jason Alexander suffers a George
Costanza moment …
Garofalo goof
After countless dates, girlfriends dumped
for petty reasons, and otherwise failed relationships,
it looked like Jerry might have finally found
his match, played by Janeane Garofalo, in
the seventh season episode "The Invitations"
...
"I tell ya, we've got tremendous — you've
got a line."
"Yeah."
"I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm kissing Jerry Seinfeld.
I get nervous!"
"It's good luck to kiss a Jew on Passover."
"Janeane thinks it's good luck to kiss a Jew
on Passover."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!